on a cliffhanger about my ex who owes me about $60,000
financial abuse is so very real and so insidious
because women are always the ones who are accused of being gold diggers
but that is the story that men have made up
and ever since women entered the workforce
they are trying to pay us as little as they can
and take as much of our money as they can
just about every single abusive relationship I've been in
unfortunately
there've been a couple
we all know how that goes
until until you heal yourself
you're gonna continue finding different versions of yourself
pointing out the areas that you need to heal
enough about that
uh in every single one of them there has been financial abuse
you know it somehow it's my fault that they're in this situation
and because they're spending so much of their time and energy on me
I owe them my money because they can't work or they can't earn as much
if they wouldn't have been giving so much to me
or some version of some bullshit story
they need to borrow some money
they need to stay with you
like they are just using and abusing women and leaving us in the dust
and it is not a measure of intelligence
it is a measure of their manipulation and willingness to be cruel